[musique]
Je voudrais que tu arrêtes quand tu l'utilises
Après tout, vous utiliserez vos yeux, vous devrez donc vous concentrer là-dessus.
En conséquence, plutôt que de blesser l'autre personne vous-même,
trébuchant
Je ne comprends pas la petite danseuse
qu'est-ce que c'est
Des blessures mineures peuvent survenir
[musique]
C'est à Abe de décider si c'est dangereux simplement parce qu'il a vu un smartphone.
Il y a peut-être des gens qui sont d'accord entre eux, mais pour moi qui est classé 9ème en vélos
Il y a aussi des dangers
probablement pas
Je n'ai pas dit que je prendrais une seule photo comme je l'ai vu
ne peut pas être un rendez-vous
dans ce sens
Les enseignants n'ont aucun problème dans le monde
[musique]